Incomplete? A masterpiece? "Across the
Spider-Verse" has seemingly drummed up
every opinion in the multiverse. Here's
what early Twitter reviews have to say.
Of the many Spider-Man-centric projects to release
in the past few years, few have built up as much
hype as "Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse." The
long-awaited sequel to the 2018 hit "Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse" has taken a
while to reach the silver screen,
but it looks to be more than worth the wait.
In continuing the story of Miles Morales,
who has come into his own as his universe's
Spider-Man, the film will showcase a litany
of Spider-People from all corners of
the seemingly infinite multiverse.
"You?"
"Wait, you?"
Unlike his first exposure to the
multiverse, however, this time around,
it seems that Miles doesn't solely encounter new
allies. From the villain known as the Spot to the
universe-hopping, vampiric Spider-Man of the
year 2099, to countless other Spider-Beings,
it appears that Miles has his work cut
out for him as he navigates different
universes. Thankfully, he has old
friends on his side to help him out.
As "Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse" begins
its run on the silver screen, the vast majority
of fans have already taken to social media
to sing the film's praises. One user tweeted:
"This is the best Spiderman movie. This is
the best animated movie. This is the best
movie. This is a work of art that flew by and
I want to watch this again a million times."
After calling it their pick for best movie of
the year, another user highlighted the sheer
artistry of the feature by assessing
every single frame as a "masterpiece."
"I'd pay good money to see that."
Meanwhile, at least one person
admitted that it surpassed their
expectations and even overtook its
predecessor in their eyes. Other
users took to comparing it to other films on
the Marvel and DC slate, with one writing:
"Across the spiderverse just embarrasses
every other [comic book movie]."
One common theme among fans is that even
though they just saw it for the first time,
they're already up for another "Across
the Spider-Verse" screening. And i
would be wise to prepare for a wild
ending, according to tweet that read:
"THAT ENDING I NEED TO TALK TO
SOMEONE WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT TO ME."
Even though "Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse"
is only just now in theaters, those who've
seen it early are already looking toward the
future. "Spider-Man: Beyond the Spider-Verse"
has been announced as the film's follow-up, thus
completing the "Spider-Verse" trilogy, and "Across
the Spider-Verse" has fans more than ready to see
what the threequel has in store. One user wrote:
"Across the spiderverse is an absolute masterpiece
and I think it'll only be beaten
by whatever the hell part 2 is."
Another person, who referred
to "Across the Spider-Verse"
as "peak cinema" in their Twitter post, added:
"Beyond the spider-verse can't come soon enough."
Many folks appear to agree, and
that's largely because "Across"
and "Beyond" are the first and second
parts of a whole story. Thus, as one
fan points out, "Across" might feel like
an incomplete story to many moviegoers.
"Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse" has been
showered with love and positivity from all sides,
with the only truly divisive element of it
being whether it deserves to be placed above
"Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse"
or not. You can now determine where
you stand since the long-awaited sequel is
currently playing exclusively in theaters.